[Music]
last night's very live episode of
America's Got down it seems that
everything that could go wrong went
wrong and Simon you just got served my
brother by scary spikes you should know
if you say something inappropriate it's
gonna get like stuff thrown at him I'm
kind of arriving this would be like
nobies wedding nights I make sure
there's no ice in it this time Nobby is
out I was thinking I think she wishes
that there was some puppy in that Cup
unleashing her inner x-men storm both
with her look and her actions Mel be
triggered a category-5 downpour on Simon
after he delivered that crude comment
she is in the midst of a very nasty
divorce and custody battle with ex
Stephen Belafonte last night she was not
happy
how'd that end I told him who he was and
that was it the heated exchange went
down after an escape artist stunt failed
due to a technical difficulty how tense
was it really could I me Simon Dean walk
the carpet tonight oh he did it
Heidi got caught in their crossfire and
that wasn't the only glitch that
happened last night we can't transmit
the lights right now post Tyra Banks
tells us what you didn't see on air I
heard
Tyra go out there go but no way don't go
out there wait go out there wait don't
go out there it was crazy like that that
was not Damien's fault I'm bringing
Inglewood up into Hollywood tonight I
need to just make sure this thing keeps
going and that we don't spontaneously
combust up into the Eclipse that just
left us you know what it seems like all
the drama was good for ratings because
of a gt1 a night with Morgan
million viewers
[Music]
you